[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zema and on
monday night's bachelor in paradise it
was all about
look what you made me do yes look what
you made jasmine do kristen where should
i say sunshine look what you made matt
do jasmine i just think that
uh i'm ready to go home
bottom line there was big time drama
jasmine said that newcomer kristen knew
she and matt were dating and kristin
took matt out anyway jasmine then
proceeded to basically chase kristen
down the beach i should say something
right like she's dead giving us this
line we've been looking forward to all
season you want good tv abc i'm about to
give you good tv
ultimately matt chose to leave paradise
to avoid this dramatic love triangle
i just think that
uh i'm ready to go home
so what did you guys think of monday
night's episode we also had another love
triangle continuing of course dean
christina and danielle with dean giving
both of the ladies some lip service
you're like literally the most
fascinating person i've ever met my
entire life i care so much more about
the way that you feel than danielle i
was never expecting you to be as
interesting as you are i'm very very
very infatuated by you let me know your
thoughts over on twitter
[Music]
you